merci l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au gouvernement
la parole est à monsieur dominique
d'ordre c'est le pr monsieur le premier
ministre
comme le dit le président ça va mieux
vos amis de l'ultra gauche semble
désormais vouloir assurer la sécurité
des français en plein état d'urgence en
restant la nuit debout place de la
république les policiers ne se font pas
agresser dans les manifestations votre
politique n'a finalement gendrey qu'un
petit million de chômeurs
supplémentaires
et comme vous allez sortir des
statistiques 500000 formation ça devrait
aller encore beaucoup mieux on peut
penser que l'unef à laquelle vous avez
promise une surtaxation des cdd va
donner l'exemple en créant elle même
quelques milliers de cdi
peut-être aussi imaginons nous que areva
va bien et qu edf n'a aucune perspective
difficile devant elle les communes de
france sont toujours debout malgré la
purge historique que vous leur avez
infligé des enfants de france sont
rayonnantes santé grâce à leur nouveau
rythme scolaire
ça va mieux les le front national quant
à lui n'est pas aux portes du second
tour de l'élection présidentielle pour
la deuxième fois dans notre histoire
après cinquante socialisme ça va mieux
votre ministre de l'économie ne vous
défie pas ni même le président de la
république
il veut simplement se mettre en marche
pour vous aider nos agriculteurs ne sont
pas désespérée nos pme ne sont pas
découragés ça va mieux votre majorité au
parlement est solide comme jamais les
frondeurs ne feront plus et le 49-3 ne
sera pas utilisée avant la semaine
prochaine
à un an des élections le président de la
république lui-même ne multiplie pas les
cadeaux électoraux avec de l'argent
qu'il n'a pas en faisant des promesses
semaine après semaine alors monsieur le
premier ministre je me demandais c'est
ma question si vous ne devriez pas comme
le président vous mettre désormais à
faire l'éloge des mous la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre manuel
valls
monsieur le député monsieur dominique
dord il ya quelque chose
en effet qui ne va pas mieux en france
c'est l'opposition et sa capacité à
faire des propositions je connais votre
talent votre ironie nous la retrouvons
régulièrement dans cet hémicycle et
c'est pour ça qu'on vous apprécient mais
essayons tout simplement de regarder
objectivement et avec lucidité la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
oui oui ça va mieux en effet et le
gouvernement assume pleinement cet état
ça va mieux en matière de croissance
quand il y à 1,1 pour cent en 2015 et
une perspective confirmée par les
chiffres qui viennent d'être publiées de
croissance pour l'année 2016 oui ça va
mieux pour notre économie
quand les chiffres du chômage baisse
comme c'est le cas au mois de mars
oui ça va mieux paco le gouvernement pas
pour la majorité seulement mais d'abord
pour les français qui sont concernés
directement par cette baisse du chômage
quand nous faisons le bilan comme nous
le faisons au cours de ces jours ci de
la refondation de l'école des postes qui
ont été créés de la baisse des
inégalités
oui monsieur le député ça va mieux
surtout quand on le compare avec le
bilan sur ce sujet comme sur d'autres
qui a été le vôtre
quand vous étiez au gouvernement alors
il suffit pas uniquement d'ironiser ou
de caricaturer il s'agit aussi de
comparer et moi mesdames et messieurs de
l'opposition
je vous attends en effet sur le bilan et
sur le projet parce que ce que vous
préparez pour le pays
c'est précisément moins de
fonctionnaires dans l'éducation
nationale dans la police - de militaire
dans la gendarmerie et dans les armées
ce que vous proposez c'est pas une
baisse des impôts c'est la baisse des
impôts pour les plus riches alors que
nous ne baissons les impôts pour les
classes moyennes et les couches
populaires
alors monsieur le député au lieu de m
l'ironie au coeur de toute intervention
faites des propositions faites en sorte
que les français dans quelques mois puis
choisir et au fond et le président la
république l'indiquait il y a un instant
il ya sans doute des modèles des projets
des perspectives pour le pays qui sont
en train de se dessiner autour de trois
baies l'idée première c'est celle du
progrès et de l'idée que nous nous
faisons du progrès je viens de parler de
l'école pourrait parler de l'université
on pourrait parler de la recherche
il y à l'idée du compromis du compromis
dans la négociation et c'est le sens du
texte de loi que va défendre dans un
instant miam quelques bris dont je veux
saluer l'action le courage et la
pugnacité pour défendre son texte et
c'est un texte utile pour les
entreprises et qui est bon pour les
salariés et puis il ya une autre idée
qui est celle de la cohésion de la
cohésion républicaine et la cohésion
nationale et franchement niro lisons pas
là dessus
monsieur le député je veux rendre
hommage comme le fera j'imagine dans un
instant le ministre de l'intérieur aux
forces de sécurité aux policiers et aux
gendarmes qui font un travail difficile
de maintien de l'ordre parmi bien
d'autres tâches et je condamne et je
condamne avec la plus grande sévérité
ceux qui se livrent à des actes
inqualifiables à l'égard des forces de
l'ordre comme je condamne les propos de
ceux qui s'abritent derrière les
casseurs pour mettre en cause et les
forces de l'ordre et les préfets
ministre de l'intérieur et le
gouvernement et ce discours dont le taux
longs de la même manière à chaque fois
la violence au moment des manifestations
contre le mariage pour tous et les
violences aujourd'hui le gouvernement et
la majorité sont cohérents et new castle
discours alors nous sommes dans un
moment où plutôt que de l'ironie oui il
faut défendre la nation la france et la
république c'est le sens de l'action du
gouvernement